[Music]
all right thank you I'm thanks Tim
Burley for the invitation in fact when
she originally invited me to submit a
proposal I was thinking well I I don't
know what I do in canvas that is special
or is different from what other people
do I've never seen the competition I've
certainly never used quizzes or or some
of these embedding of multimedia
material on canvas essentially sort of
sums up the way that I've been using
canvas and I think it boils down to the
way that I've used the homepage as the
go-to resource for a lot of things that
we do in class so just to give you a bit
of background knowing right here is a
pretty large statistics class there's
about a hundred students and we don't
have regular quizzes and tests we do
have sort of two exams throughout the
semester but we do have regular reading
assignments and homework assignments and
so on so one of the questions that I'm
sure you all have from students is sort
of what's what's the homework or what's
the reading assignment where can I find
this that we did in class and for me the
easiest way to just put everything in a
central place has been to make use of
the homepage this is just one of the
pages that I've created and I sort of
clicked to set it as the homepage and I
designed it to be sort of a growing
syllabus if you will so initially it'll
be a week 1 of class and you probably
won't see very much beyond say up to
this point and so there will be
essential information like who are the
TAS in the course who are the you LA's
we use you always in this course as well
when are there office hours and all this
is dynamic in the sense that we can
change it at any time it's so it's a
website that we can sort of go in modify
as needed in order to get sort of the
most up-to-date information so and the
way that things progressed is obviously
you know the important things are way at
the top and then I like to organize my
material on a week to week basis so I
try to have a top level heading per week
it's just week one the date what did we
cover in class what are the slides that
go along
with a material in class and what are
some sort of computer code examples that
would come along with that I mean I
think that this gives me just a very
nice way of pointing students to the
page I can even say things like if you
happen to miss class feel free to just
keep up to date by looking at what's
going on on the homepage everything is
posted there you wouldn't miss anything
the only that's missing is maybe videos
of our in-class lectures but I'm very
resistant against that kind of thing
things that that I would want to
highlight is I did try doing something
like this with the modules section of
canvas and I heard a lot of you use
canvas very successfully so I do have a
slight example from an earlier a
different course when I did try to
implement the same kind of thing using
modules and I thought this would make my
life easier because I could just go
ahead and create these high-level
folders from week to week I can include
assignments I can include any other
files that I'd like to include normally
and by what I found is that this is a
little less flexible it's much harder
for me to format the names of things
include bold facing for things I'd like
to highlight I'm and it takes up a lot
of space so week 1 for this class for
example stretches what fold page
basically I just scroll down to get to
week 2 and whereas I tend now to prefer
just having everything on this home page
where I can even have things that are
just just text right so things like when
office hours are links to practice exams
solutions to practice exams having it
all be in that one central place seems
to me the easiest way to go I guess they
still have time remaining so since this
is not a canvas propaganda session I
think I want to also talk a little bit
about the struggles that I've had with
canvas if I may since I have an audience
and so in my class we have about four
people five people grading for every
single assignment and we do make use of
canvases grading tool I really do like
the speed grader that everybody can go
in and see the PDF submissions they can
annotate the PDFs work with a rubric
and this makes it really easy if you
don't want people to be swapping back
and forth paper assignments for example
one challenge that I've had however is
that if you have multiple people grading
simultaneously the rubric be very
careful because they will sometimes
overwrite each other's points and I've
had that when two graders were grading
simultaneously someone may be grading
problem one someone grading problem five
and maybe they're just offset by a
couple of students and somebody will
click on submit and save and boom the
other grade completely disappears into
thin air so I'm hoping that someday
we're able to resolve this I see this as
sort of the main complaint that I have
with canvas in the meantime but
otherwise I think the students have been
fairly satisfied with being able to have
everything in in one place oops sorry
about that and and being able to sort of
see their grades see their feedback and
being able to submit things very easily
without having to appear in person to
turn things in that's all I'm I don't
know if I understood you clearly so
presume to teach and fellows are grading
simultaneously the same assignment they
would be doing it why is it accidental
or you deliberately assigned like the TF
one will grade problems one to two and
tf2 will great problems three to four I
mean why would that problem occur that's
a very good question so in in my mind
because we want to have our you all A's
and TAS grade consistently we want to
instead of having them great different
students maybe they just create
different problems and that way
everybody you know one TF will greet all
of problem one one table grade all the
problem two and so in that case it is
possible for two of them to be grading
the same person simultaneously
can you set it so that the students
receive an email announcement when you
update the homepage I have not figured
out how to do that that would certainly
be ideal I should look into that I think
that would be an excellent sort of
improvement upon the current system to
have students see that new material has
been posted I don't think that happens
on pages unfortunately it is assignments
you can do it for assignments but not on
pages right now okay someday thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]